donc voilà le 2022
le sauvignon gris
et on va chercher
et c'est comme ça au bout de 60 jours
voire plus qu'on va aller chercher cette
couleur donc on garde un fruit différent
mais on a cette couleur qui arrive pour
aller justement sur ces tons orange
[Musique]
c'était un cépage d'autrefois qui
faisait du vin paysan c'est vache qui
donne beaucoup c'est un cépage qui a
pour caractéristique d'être très peu
d'alcoolisées autrefois il donnait des
vins à 7 8 degrés aujourd'hui avec le
réchauffement climatique on est plutôt
sur 11 ans et demi sur ces 20 là tous
ces cépages d'autres fois mais c'est de
retrouver les équilibres retrouver des
cépages qui peut-être qui mûrissaient
pas autrefois qui avait trop d'acidités
pas assez de degrés d'alcool et qui dans
ces conditions là vont vont vont
reprendre leurs lettres de noblesse